das war alles die dich hört doch auf
alle staaten an das leben erlebt ich
irgendwann
denken bisher
jeder kennt das leben
jeder link
apa
leider vergessen würdest du dann wenn
ein schande sich schlägt
gut mit dem politischen wort herzlich
willkommen zudem lockt ich bin mit nahe
zusammen bei der es gerade aufgestanden
wir wahrscheinlich im print
hier im innenhof steht die schwalbe also
das moped mit dem ich meinen unfall
hatte da bin ich mit dem teil hier
gefahren im ersten gang wollte anfahren
west der gaszug gerissen und das hat
vollgas gegeben und ich bin jetzt nur
zwei autos eingefangen gut so wir waren
seit der letzten sache die ihr gesehen
habt lange weg ungefähr drei stunden
oder so wir waren burger essen waren wir
noch was anderes wäre es ja und wir sind
umgefallen weil das hotel wo wir drin
sind rave aus berlin lobte placement
aber schau das ist so cool also wirklich
vielleicht schaut ja nochmal verband
gebe ich dann ruhte aber das muss jetzt
halt noch heute kommen freunde so was
haben wir nicht erwartet
gentrifizierung mach's doch andere
menschen haben enorme 4 unterlagen
ich habe eine plastiktüte von ktw alle
vor der andere leute zusammen hier
unterlagen gar nichts mit bmi okay leute
ich hab euch hier gerade schon gesagt
hey ich habe ja gerade schon gesagt dass
wir die ganze zeit unterwegs waren und
jetzt ist es schon sein es ist jetzt
schon 17 42 ich fahre jetzt zurück ins
hotel
und wenn dort mein blog blog dass wir
jetzt gerade seht schneidet aber es ist
besser als nichts
+ ihr habt unsere gesichter gesehen
ich hätte eigentlich auch so ein
bisschen mit filmen können aber sollen
wir zwar auch für sap kommt am montag
zurück nach hause und dann
wenn wir dort eine coole geschichte
machen zb machen wir mit der elgato so
eine kleine iphone battle challenge das
wird lustig weiß das schon jetzt schon
ab sondern auf jeden fall ist für cool
ich hoffe das ist in ordnung und jetzt
hab gehört dass hier seit zufrieden oder
beleidigt ja chips und feiert